alright I guess we'll go ahead and get
started hi my name is Evan ought i'm a
statistic socked oral student at the
University of Texas at Austin I'm also
part of the Wolfram student ambassador
program for UT so hook em horns and
guess start off happy a world statistics
day everybody not sure if you know that
that's a thing but it is a thing and
it's today so today I'm going to be
talking about a project I've been
working on since this summer trying to
bring several different Wolfram language
tools together to look at election 2016
it's a fairly simple model right now but
the hope that I have for this talk is
that you'll be able to see how several
different technologies can play together
into something that I think is kind of
innovative and something that should be
able to be applicable for anything that
you're trying to do so with that just a
brief little outline I'll say you know a
little bit more about myself just so you
know kind of the background that I'm
coming from then we'll get to the stuff
that you actually care about which is
the blog that I've been working on
mathematic shun talk about some of the
things that I've been doing with it then
go in to the technology not maybe not
quite as ad hoc as some of Stephens
presentations where he'll do a lot of
live coding i'll have like one little
snippet a little more nervous than he is
about doing such things but we'll talk
about the Wolfram data drop how to use
it a little bit then quick little thing
on some of the kind of data analysis
that I've been doing for this project
and then how cloud deploy works for all
of this and some of the cool
applications when you bring all this
together so like I said I'm from UTI
background in physics and computer
science really was introduced to
Mathematica more from a data analysis
type perspective so not a lot of people
used it at the time but my junior year I
actually created a small course and
small textbook that currently isn't
hosted anywhere I'm figuring that out
and but how to do some introductory data
analysis with Mathematica
so that's kind of my approach that's how
I view a lot of Wolfram sings is kind of
more from how can I analyze data how can
I do things so the blog I've been really
interested in this election I think it's
going to be a fascinating one with the
pace of Technology I've been personally
making some predictions since january
2014 on reddit obviously just kind of a
very you know oh I'm going to predict
this okay well that's great and all but
can we do this with some data and that
was the genesis of my blog mathematic
shin here is just kind of scrolling
through some of the things that I've
been doing you're welcome to check it
out you can follow it all that cool
stuff that work started and in July so
let's take a look at some of that what
I've been doing is collecting the likes
for each candidate on facebook now this
is a very simple metric you know it's
not really following as good as some
datasets have of down to the county or
things of that nature but it gives a
pretty good estimate I think of okay
who's popular what's going on in
particular the trends in the data here
I'm just playing this through time you
can see and sorting by the total number
of likes you can see the relative
ordering change well maybe that's just a
false little something that's going on
but maybe there's something really to
that in particular when we look at some
other visualizations like this one so
this is just looking at all the
different candidates the current
facebook frontrunner ben Carson is
highlighted there you can see some
interesting things starts show up so the
vertical bars there the first and second
GOP debates and there's a pretty
significant impact on Facebook
popularity in accordance with these like
real world events that are going on and
I don't know being able to display this
in a really easy manner that you know
there was there's a lot going on in this
graph but it's fairly easy to see oh hey
this highlighted thing ben Carson is in
the lead and that seems to kind of
correspond you know maybe not exactly
with
a real political landscape but certainly
not too far from it so how am i doing
all of this I'm really basing a lot of
this work on the Wolfram data drop so if
you're not familiar with it i know
stephen's had a few words about it
during the keynote it's a very flexible
way of storing data in the cloud in
particular you can bring in data from
anywhere so although all of my data is
just Facebook Likes trying to grab
something from Facebook this could be
any sensor anywhere in the world that
has an internet connection if you
haven't seen it work or just a very
simple example I'm loading in a data bit
loading a data been adding a couple of
rows to it and then displaying it as a
data set so we get this nice structured
database type table of data i can start
computing with that immediately this is
perhaps not the most useful thing but
here I'm taking all of the time stamps
so whenever you submit something it gets
a timestamp these you know are separated
by few milliseconds but you can cast
those into a date object and now we can
start doing things with time series
Stephen did that actually during the
keynote a little bit and one of the
other things that he mentioned is that
all of this is accessible via a web api
that's really cool because one we have
all of these interactive devices that
are already integrated into the Wolfram
language but even ones that aren't as
long as they have an internet connection
and can hit a URL they can start adding
their own data in whatever way that you
come up with that's really flexible
that's really powerful so data data can
come to us from anywhere gets stored in
the cloud and we can access that
anywhere with Wolfram language so
although I really want this part of my
project to be in Wolfram language I've
not yet tried that so I have a little
daily JavaScript that goes runs a little
query on Facebook for each candidate
gets the number of likes stores it in
the day to drop
and so this is kind of what my raw data
looks like so for each candidate I have
the total number of likes at a given
time and I have you know a couple of
months worth of data on this so what do
I do with that data well have to do some
kind of exploratory data analysis
because especially for the blog type
scenario it's not a matter of only
figuring out okay who's the leader who's
this but it's trying to figure out what
interesting things have happened what's
going on what are some trends what did
we think is going to happen soon and you
know typical example using manipulate so
I would guess probably most of the
people in this room have used it for
something before I think it's really
kind of cool if you put just a little
bit of effort into it you can make some
really interactive nice displays such as
this one where I can look at several
different views of the data really
easily just with a click of a couple
buttons so I can look at the total
number of likes I can trace that through
time so we can see kind of relative
proportions of candidates who's doing
well I can look at for example the
overnight change between candidates I
can filter by just using the Democrats
and we see okay well some nights bernie
sanders is leading some nights hillary
clinton is leading it just kind of
depends but by adding just a little bit
of extra work in terms of labeling
things this is really easy to figure out
what's going on so you can you know for
me I can take off my software
engineering hat put on my data scientist
hat and start figuring out okay what's
really going on let me take a look at
this and similarly you know there's all
kinds of fitting functions built into
mathematica if you haven't used them
they're very powerful very
straightforward to use here just taking
a linear model of the data since the
first GOP debate since several
candidates started skyrocketing since
then Carly Fiorina and ben Carson in
particular and what i can do is i can
take a linear model fit for each
candidate starting then and i can
propagate that out in time
and then sort by the total number of
likes at that time so here we can look
at all the data up to today extrapolate
that out words starting tomorrow we can
see okay well pretty soon George Bush
will pass Scott Walker now here later on
Bernie Sanders will pass people and we
get the Super Tuesday and all the way to
the election congratulations president
Carson I guess we'll see um obviously
linear model fit not exactly
representative of the real world
political landscape but it's a good
first guess right and you know yeah
extrapolations terrible but this is
something interesting this gives us
something to work with this gives us
something to say you know asthma as a
blogger I can go and say hey this is
what I predict let's see what happens
now let's update this prediction let's
use more sophisticated analysis point is
all of this functionality all of these
different views and things all I'd have
to do is change my model here so instead
of a linear model fit maybe I fed a
slightly different function to it I do
some change point analysis to figure out
okay when the debates happen these kinds
of things tend to happen I need to model
it a little bit differently that's
really powerful because now I have all
of this sort of display to use I can you
know do all my data science i can do all
my exploratory data analysis very
straightforwardly cloud to play so i've
seen Stephen do a couple of different
talks he was at UT this past year and
did some things with cloud deploy
showing various sorts of API type
functions he demonstrated some of those
today and it's really cool to see you
know things like image identify right we
can deploy that to the web people can
upload an image and have very simple
functionality ready to go that's really
cool because that brings power to the
people so I've done that on my blog with
one function already just kind of I've
was kind of beating my head against the
wall about a couple of things with it
that
not to just be missing a few characters
but it happens what i can do is i can
create using cloud deploy using forms
things like that i can create ways for
people who never touched a line of code
to interact with data in a new way so
they can look at the same kind of things
that i'm looking at but maybe they'll be
able to see something that i missed or
maybe they want to run something that i
haven't considered which is really cool
because that gets people engaged in data
engaged in whatever you're working on
maybe you're doing something where
you're comparing I don't know several
different pricing models vendors and
distributors well you can encode all of
that deploy it to the cloud get it ready
to go and now anybody at your company
can play around with it and say oh hey
what about this that's kind of cool and
so with live results one of the cool
things here is as we start to integrate
all of these kinds of things together so
we have the manipulate type of thing we
can do all sorts of model fitting we can
read data in from a data drop well we
can also start and combining this so
here I just built a little form page I
actually updated this since the talk
this morning because I was not aware
that form page existed which much better
fits what I've been trying to do then
form function so if it's a little bit
broken I apologize but I tested it a
couple times so same kind of form as if
I was doing this in manipulate this is
all in Mathematica right now but what i
can do is i can deploy this to the cloud
sorry so this is going to create that
same kind of pie chart function going to
deploy it to the cloud i tested this
like less than an hour ago come on it'll
get there he'll go I promise while it's
working the idea here is that again
anybody anywhere can start accessing
this data it can be in real time you can
do this for yourself you can do it for
others come on
let me restart it real quick come on
baby well I guess you can take my word
for it um so we get I'll let it keep
running and we can come back to it at
the end and hopefully it'll maybe be
done we're going to play this to the
cloud people can start playing with data
and get it in a really interactive way
one of the thing trying to wrap up here
I know lunch is very soon and I don't
want to keep you from that one of the
things so I started this project I was
you know writing to a CSV and Dropbox
and having to load that you have a
computer that's running a script and
then loading it on this one so I'd kind
of built everything around the
traditional sort of mathematical lists
and I was kind of concerned with data
drop everything's in a little bit
different of a format I was really
concerned about that so I did want to
say at a very practical level data drop
is really you can incorporate it very
straightforwardly I don't know if you
can really see that pretty well I can
read in for example all of the fields of
my data so in particular if I've done
something very structured you don't have
to in date a drop but if you do you can
get you know read your columns I can
read in my data very straightforwardly
so same sort of data now in a very kind
of typical form in Mathematica so any
functions that you already have our
fully ready to be used with date with
things from the data drop so that means
whatever functionality you already have
you can start reading them from data in
real time anywhere that has an internet
connection that's really cool like come
on that's just really cool manipulate
again you know I'm sure everybody's done
something with it you can start
exploring data in a really systematic
way and making little you know
throughout this project I've made little
views for myself so you've seen kind of
things displayed in a tabular format or
in a date list plot or in a pie chart
being able to do things
you know coming up with a particular
view but then playing with it being able
to do different things so instead of ben
Carson and Donald Trump maybe I want to
look at Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton and we can see the relative
difference of those two candidates over
time I can say okay well somewhere
around here something changed for some
reason maybe I've done some kind of
sophisticated analysis on that and I can
say okay well here I'll just change the
my starting point for that linear model
fit and so now I have a new estimate
based on saying okay based on some prior
analysis but I can do all of that just
with a few sliders that's really cool
and lastly I want to go back AHA I knew
it would work so here I go this will
create a pie chart for me it's
processing I can see it it's going it's
going alright come on and live demos man
and there we go so that that's a cloud
deploy that I just wrote I mean you saw
me write it obviously some of the
backend functionality I've written many
weeks ago but this is ready to go and
all I have to do to start looking at
different views I can just click it will
update it may take a couple seconds here
we go so as I was saying before like
this is really impressive I can do this
wive also so going back to this slide
looking at the data that little toy
example with the speakers for today I
can deploy this I can delay reading in
the data until when it's accessed if
this doesn't work oh well point is with
data drop you can actually read that
data in live when the user accesses it
which means that you can get real-time
results not just gathering data all the
time from anywhere now you can read in
that live so you're not limited
so here we see the three roads that were
already there so Stephen at nine me now
Stephen again later tonight for live
coding i can add another row to that
data bent and reload this page and voila
my talk that started approximately 20
minutes ago I can do all of this wife so
I hope I've been able to show you some
kind of cool examples of things I'm
happy to stick around and talk about any
of the technology that i've been using
if you want to ask some political
questions about what's been going on I'm
happy to create some things for you but
with that I think I'll call it a day and
taking questions